miles de musulmanes rojin ya que viven
en india están en pánico desde la semana
pasada luego de que el gobierno
anunciara que los trasladaría centros de
detención hasta que fueran deportados a
mianmar este hombre login ya de 22 años
y su familia pasaron ocho meses en uno
de sus centros de detención en delhi el
año pasado por temor a represalias nos
cuenta su historia de forma anónima
ni siquiera puede explicar lo difícil
que fue está más allá de lo que puedas
imaginar a menudo lloraba allí también
había familias con niños niños pequeños
no se nos permitió contactar a nadie
afuera pensé que era mejor suicidarme si
tenía que quedarme unos días más mi
madre estaba muy enferma y nadie nos
ayudaba pues una manita se estima que
40.000 refugiados rohingya viven en
india algunos han estado allí desde la
década de 1970 pero muchos llegaron
después de 2012 cuando estalló la
violencia en mianmar los sentimientos
anti musulmanes van en aumento desde que
el gobierno de derecha del partido
popular indio llegó al poder en 2014 los
expertos en derechos humanos dicen que
los musulmanes rohingyas se han
convertido en una herramienta para en la
islamofobia
campeón
la campaña del partido de gobierno es
divisiva como pueden ver grande una
falsa sensación de miedo
los musulmanes son el objetivo y entre
los musulmanes los rohingyas son el
objetivo más fácil
en delhi más de 1000 rohingyas viven en
malas condiciones en campamentos como
este nos encontramos con el líder de
esta comunidad de 50 familias tampoco
quiere ser identificado por temor a una
reacción violenta a
devolver
los he escuchado llamarnos infiltrados
terroristas nos insultan me duele mucho
esas palabras me hace preguntarme dónde
estoy y qué estoy haciendo aquí antes
era mejor que me al mar pero ahora
sentimos que nos enfrentamos a la misma
violencia aquí a eso es a lo que le
tenemos miedo a
los refugiados rohingya no están
dispuestos a regresar hasta que sea
seguro para ellos en mianmar